SHOULD NOT SEE ANOTHER DIME FROM
WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IN OFFICE,
I’D DON’T THINK THEY WILL.
HERE’S THE HOST OF SPECIAL
REPORT WITH BRET BAIER, WHAT
THEY ARE SAYING, THEY DON’T
BELIEVE THE OUTBREAK WAS LINKED
TO ANY KIND OF MAN-MADE
BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS PROGRAM
ACCORDING TO YOUR REPORT.
THEY DON’T BELIEVE THE
CONTAMINATION WAS INTENTIONAL.
IT DO WE KNOW THIS FOR CERTAIN,
OR IS THERE A POSSIBILITY THAT
IT WAS MANUFACTURED?
IT WAS INTENTIONAL?
YOU CONFIRMED IN YOUR RECORDING
THEY PROTECTED THEIR COUNTRY,
BUT THEY LEFT THE REST OF THIS
WORLD GET THIS VIRUS.
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING.
THERE IS REALLY ZERO CONFIDENCE
IN PEOPLE I’VE TALKED TO,
PUBLICLY THAT THIS WAS A
MAN-MADE VIRUS.
IT YOU HEARD IT TONY FAUCI ASK
THIS QUESTION IN A WAY ABOUT THE
LAB IN THE WHITE HOUSE
TASK FORCE BRIEFING TONIGHT, HE
SAID THERE WERE A LOT OF STUDIES
THAT SHOWED IT WAS TRANSMITTED
FROM ANIMAL TO HUMAN AND THAT IT
WAS NOT GENETICALLY ALTERED.
THAT MATCH WHAT OUR SOURCES HAD
SAID.
WE DIDN’T THINK BASED ON THE
STRUCTURE OF THE GENOME OF THE
VIRUS THAT IT WAS MAN-MADE.
NOW, THE THING THAT IS
INCONCLUSIVE IS EXACTLY ABOUT
THE LAB.
MORE AND MORE DOTS, BOTH OPEN
SOURCE AND CLASSIFIED POINT
RIGHT TO THE LAB.
THAT’S WHY WE ARE INCREASING IN
CONFIDENCE.
WHAT THERE IS 100% CONFIDENCE
OF, WE REPORTED THIS, MORE
OFFICIALS ARE SAYING IT
PUBLICLY, IS THE LEVEL OF EXTENT
OF THE COVER-UP CHINA WENT TO,
AND PART OF THOSE DOTS FIT INTO
WHY THERE IS SUCH A POINT AT
LOOKING AT THIS LAB.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT IT
PUBLICLY TODAY.
>> Sean: WE DO KNOW THIS FROM
SIZE, MOST PEOPLE MAY NOT
REMEMBER SARS WAS ALSO A
CORONAVIRUS ACCORDING TO THE
SCIENTISTS
AND DOCTORS I INTERVIEWED, WHEN
THEY BROKE DOWN THE SEQUENCE IN
RECORD TIME, WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
IN STAGE ONE TRIALS FOR THE
VACCINE, THERE WAS A 98% SIMILAR
SEQUENCE AS SARS, ANOTHER
CORONAVIRUS WHICH WOULD LEND
ITSELF TO THE THEORY THAT THEY
DIDN’T DO THIS INTENTIONALLY,
MEANING, CREATE THE VIRUS.
IT WAS THERE.
WHAT IS THE EXACT EVIDENCE THAT
THEY ARE GIVING YOU?
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING
SPECIFICALLY BEHIND THIS REPORT
THAT PROVES THIS?
>> Bret: ON THE MAN-MADE PART,
THEY BELIEVE IT WAS DR. SURE
SINGLEY WHO WAS WORKING IN THE
WUHAN LAB WAS ESSENTIALLY
WORKING ON ANTIVIRAL
IMMUNIZATION EFFORTS.
THAT’S WHAT OUR SOURCES ARE
SAYING.
THAT’S WHAT MATCHES SOME OF THE
REPORTS THAT WERE OUT FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTH CHINA AND
OTHERS.
THERE WERE AUTHOR’S TO STUDY THE
VIRUS
IN THE VERY LAB.
A SICKLY, THE NONMAN-MADE PART
IS POINTING SPECIFICALLY TO THE
GENETIC MAPPING OF THIS VIRUS
RIGHT NOW.
IT HOPPED FROM AN ANIMAL TO
HUMAN, AND IT WAS NOT ALTERED IN
ITS GENETIC SEQUENCE.
>> AND JUST TO BE CLEAR, AND
YOUR REPORTING YOU ARE SAYING
THAT IT WAS THE CHINESE KNEW IT
WAS DANGEROUS ENOUGH THAT THEY
WEREN’T ALLOWING FLIGHTS IN OR
OUT OF WUHAN TO ANY OTHER PART
OF CHINA, BUT THEY WERE ALLOWING
IT TO THE REST OF THE WORLD,
WHICH WOULD SAY THEY KNEW IT WAS
THAT DANGEROUS?
>> Bret: IT THEN YOU LOOK AT
OTHER ELEMENTS THEY ARE, DOTS ON
THE BOARD, THAT IS HOW MUCH THEY
WENT TO SCRUB ALL OF THE DATA.
THE FACT THAT YOU CAN FIND SOME
OF THESE DOCTORS, INCLUDING HIM
DOMINIC LEE, WHO IS
WORKING ON IT.
SOME OF THE SAMPLES WERE
DESTROYED, THE FACT THAT JUST
TODAY, SEAN, THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT RE-ANNOUNCED AN
INCREASE IN THE DOTS TOTAL IN
WUHAN BY 50%.
>> Sean: WHAT A JOKE.
>> Bret: THAT’S JUST TODAY.